[Music]
good idea welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight for two long years Jim Comey has
played the role of America's moral
martyr and for two years it's basically
worked for him in the closing days of
2016 you'll remember Comey was likely
the most hated man on the American
laughte that bizarre press conference he
held in July of that year in which he
described hillary clinton has legally
innocent but morally guilty may in the
end have cost democrats the election
it's possible and they hated him for
less than a year later though Donald
Trump fired Jim Comey as FBI director
and whatever Trump dislikes liberals
love and so Comey was back in their good
graces once again he's done his best
ever since to remain there coming titled
his book a higher loyalty meaning that
he unlike you is a man of principle
accountable only to his God and
conscience in contrast to your grubby
little political concerns Jim Comey is
the last honest man in America he makes
that point every time he appears in
public and as a man of integrity Jim
Comey would like you to know that
despite the fact he's got no actual
evidence to support the claim
he's pretty certain Vladimir Putin has
been blackmailing Donald Trump since day
one I honestly never thought these words
would come out of my mouth but I don't
know whether the current president
nighted states with prostitutes peeing
on each other in Moscow in 2013 it's
possible but I don't know yeah but it's
possible because when you run the FBI
you deal in things are just possible
well even after the DOJ inspector
general's report came out essentially
destroying Jim Comey's credibility many
of the claims that he's forwarded over
the years he persisted he published a
smug op-ed in the Washington Post
claiming to have been vindicated of all
wrongdoing why would you even call me do
that it's almost like he didn't think
you had the Internet and couldn't read
the report for yourself maybe he was so
used to being treated as untouchable
that he started to believe that he
actually was but in the end as always
happens reality intruded the IG report
didn't actually vindicate Jim Comey
instead it revealed frightful abuses of
power
by the FBI the FBI that he ran abuses
that ought to terrify Americans left
right and center Inspector General
Michael Horowitz summed it up on Capitol
Hill watch we identified significant
inaccuracies and omissions in each of
the four applications seven in the first
application and a total of seventeen by
the final renewal application what a
mission could be a mistake
it happens seventeen of them that's not
a mistake that's either malice or it's
gross incompetence or a combination of
both either way not reassuring in the
end even someone as beloved by the news
media as Jim Comey had to answer for the
17 omissions so over the weekend come he
appeared on Fox and he said this about
the IG report he's right I was wrong I
was overconfident in the procedures that
the FBI and justice had built over 20
years I thought they were a bust enough
it's incredibly hard to get a FISA I was
overconfident in those because he's
right there was real sloppiness 17
things the user should have been in the
applications or at least discussed and
characterize differently it was not
acceptable and so he's right I was wrong
it's incredibly hard to get if Isis
really how incredibly hard is it Jim
Comey specifically how many have been
turned down in the past 15 years oh you
don't have those numbers do you not many
is the real answer but that wasn't even
the most damning part of the interview
with that liar you just saw at one point
Jim Comey was asked whether lying to a
FISA Court in order to spy on an
American citizen might merit some
professional consequences here so he
responded if you were still there and
all of us came out and it turned out it
happened on your watch would you resign
no I don't think so there were mistakes
I consider more consequential than this
during my tenure and the important thing
is to be transparent about it think
about that there were worse mistakes
than knowingly using partisan lies to
spy on an American citizen but Jim Comey
won't tell you what they are because he
believes in transparency did you catch
all that that was
one sentence by the way a sentence the
contradicts itself did he would notice
no one seemed to maybe we need a new
Inspector General's investigation to
find out what the hell he's talking
about
in the meantime how worried should we be
can we trust the FBI is no longer being
used as a political tool